I’ve got a new set!
With new props like my friend Nietzsche and his
sweet but ultimately totally meaningless mustache.
And I’m here in this fancy new place to
dive into a very old discipline.
This year on Crash Course, I am excited to
be tackling some of the biggest questions
yet. What is consciousness? Truth? Goodness?
Do we even know anything? And how?
No, seriously Socrates, how do we know?
These are the daunting questions we’re going
to try to wrap our heads around this year
on Crash Course Philosophy.
While I’ve spent the last few years teaching
you different sciences, much of how we arrive
at the knowledge we have can be traced back
to Philosophy.
Like, the Socratic method of breaking things
down into simpler questions to arrive at answers
heavily influenced what we now know as the
scientific method.
In fact, the institutional ancestors to modern
universities thought of most of the subjects
we now call sciences as philosophy. Everything
was philosophy!
Because all academic inquiry was trying to
answer important questions about the world,
our place in it, and establishing a reliable,
trustworthy framework for answering those questions.
While some of the questions in philosophy
can seem a little, like, impractical, its
approach to thinking about the world actually
applies to pretty much everything.
Unlike other courses, this year we’re going
to be far less interested in making sure you
know a bunch of memorizable facts -- which
also means, thank goodness, that I won’t
have to say epithelial again all year -- and
more interested in how you think.
We’re going to talk about reasoning and
logic. How do you arrive at your own conclusions?
And can you explain them?
These are things you’re already doing every
day to make decisions about your life or whether
you can eat another corn dog. Your daily life
already consists of tons of inductive reasoning,
and probably a few encounters with people
whose ideas you might describe as “illogical.”
But because this course is less about what
you know than how you know, we’re going
to make you better at reasoning and hopefully
even understanding that relative who posts
incessant ranty status updates that drive
you crazy.
Maybe. We can’t promise miracles. If nothing
else, you’ll be better able to understand
the strengths and weakness of your own ideas
as you go forth into the world.
And that will make you a better anything -- scientist,
economist, historian, corn dog consumer.
So join us for the big questions this year
on Crash Course Philosophy, which is produced
in association with our good friends at PBS
digital studios.